so I said yesterday that the devs were
going to wait a couple weeks to change
the DLC characters but I guess I was
wrong a couple days ago as of today they
really a couple days ago after the DLC
which would be today
the devs released a hotfix for the for a
foreigner on p.a ps4 Xbox one and PC and
I guess a couple of the consoles and PC
didn't get some updates that the others
got so for Xbox one we apparently didn't
get the update we're reviving a teammate
was limited to once per round I can't
say I can confirm this because I've been
playing mostly Dominion since the update
I haven't really played too much
elimination so if anyone can for kind of
prove that statement that'd be great and
board and shoulder basher is also fixed
target switching is allowed during the
charge and the next thing is that
Centurion and shinobi were apparently
not able to unlock certain orders so now
they've been considered hybrids which
they can now receive the contact orders
dance of death squad action and tour of
duty for both hybrid and assassin the
next thing that came up is that shinobi
got a buff to wear his light attack
combo and his light finisher is now a
hit recovery has been increased by 200
milliseconds meaning it's a lot quicker
and he's a lot faster to take a block
and you'll block some hits afterwards in
terms of grab teching and heavy parried
it's a lot less punishing so for example
when if the shinobi has the long-range
guard break the only one in the game
well the animation when he throws
someone is a lot shorter so instead of
1,300 milliseconds is them 900 making it
making him you know throwing them a lot
quicker so he can get more punishing in
and he's also pulled a shorter distance
if he is if that is guard broken so if
he were to throw the guard break and you
were to tack it back he would grab the
chain and pull him forward now it what
it used to be that the farther the
distance he was from you the farther he
was away from you so you couldn't get
less punished that's why she nobodies
were always like a far distance but if
he was within a decent distance of you
you could pull him right next to your
feet and you would you could punish him
severely now he has a certain exact
distance away from the target he's
pulled regardless of where he's being
placed it's about 2.5 meters away so
it's less punishing for a shinobi to go
for this attack and
and not having to be worried of getting
killed immediately the next one is the
sickle rain mixup has now been
guaranteed if you don't know what's a
sickle rain mixup is it is the double
heavy triple light combo we're used to
the problem with this attack is that it
was so hard to pull off because you had
to get two heavies in the same stance
like to top heavies and nobody's going
to fall for that unless they have no
idea what they're doing for for honor so
the devs made it so that the first heavy
is thrown the second one is guaranteed
so that you can pull off this chain for
once and the heavy will meet
automatically pull you down to their
knees just like the combo and there was
a bug-fix where his kick and tackle
ignored jugo ki super armor or his
little hyper armor so that's been fixed
so that if you go and slide it against
shinobi or kick him with his hyper armor
on it does not affect him the next thing
is Centurion got a nerve
his kick his legion kick which is a dash
forward in X or dash forward and guard
break for anybody else the kick cost was
now increased from 12 to 25 stamina and
branching into a heavy finisher is
delayed by 200 milliseconds and the
heavy finisher is no longer guaranteed
branching into a light attack offset is
a hundred milliseconds faster and the
light attack is guaranteed after the
kick the reason they're doing this is
that they're making sure he doesn't do
too much damage because if I'm punishing
he can be with his combo and they're
making it so that the players used the
light attack more seeing is guaranteed
and it's faster instead of a heavy
attack which meaning that it's slower
and it's not guaranteed anymore
now in terms of his throw branching into
the heavy finisher immediately after his
throw is been delayed by 300
milliseconds once again making it a lot
slower and easier for players to dodge
it makes it unblockable in all
situations and it's and it is parable it
was already the case though for the
front throw and the jump attack the lat
the last 400 milliseconds of the jump
attack is not dodge able so if the if a
Centurion does the jumping attack where
if he throws you to the ground he has
that guaranteed jump attack the last 400
seconds of it is not dodge able for I'm
assuming for all characters so you can
move out of the way before he comes and
kills you which is good for shinobi
because if Shinobi's on the ground
and that happens it there goes half your
health right there anyway guys it's
going to be really it that was a quick
little HOF a so the devs devs did put
out just want to get this out to you so
that everybody knows what the deals what
happened with the DLC characters and
feels any weirder to be playing the game
but anyway guys I hope you all did enjoy
if you want to see my video previously
click the top click the card in the top
right and you'll be taken to that but
anyway guys I will see you all in the
next video and peace out